do you know any girls on the team that
messed with the coach just to be on the
team is that a thing
not at a d3 school um
but
there was a coach a basketball coach
that actually hooked up with a girl
after she graduated
so it was illegal
yeah like it was
but yeah that that's not uncommon i had
a coach in high school really that
waited yeah he
oh my gosh it's just so traumatizing
because i i was so close with him like i
was so close with him like i did
one-on-one training with him a couple
times a week did he hug you and that
makes me wait wait so he he was um
an ex-nfl player
um robert is his name robert
that sounds close to his last name
was he black yeah
oh my god 1981
oh my god dude i'm done don't even say
it on camera
how do you know him because he used to
come into twin peaks
oh my god no he he like waited until a
girls would turn i mean it was so creepy
yeah i was i used to look i remember
looking at him like a dad like for a
while because i saw him so much yeah and
then the first time i went back from
college to go because it's normal to go
see your old coaches yeah if you're an
athlete yeah and so i went to see him
and like he
yeah he he
he won the super bowl in either 81 or
83. i don't know um i don't know i
didn't see something about football was
it bears it was the bears yeah guys
yeah i i got him fired from my high
school i'm like 100 dead i was no i was
not playing because wait so what
happened i was like so so he he i was um
this was a while ago now because i think
i was 18 or 19 when this happened so i
was the first time i went back from
college okay and it was the first time
i'd seen him since i was 18 pretty much
okay so he i said oh can i come to the
gym and he was like oh let's go get
lunch and then when we went to it's like
not that weird i don't know why i didn't
think so you have to understand i didn't
do [ __ ] in high school so i was i was
very you know i would have no idea that
it got weird yet yeah so then it started
to get weird at lunch where he would
just say
i don't know you look beautiful
like oh like he would make comments on
my leggings i remember that was like the
first i was like okay but i'm very much
i give people the benefit of the doubt
so i was like oh whatever you know
you're just used to it yeah
and then he um
i forgot and then he started asking me
about like boys medic college and i was
like oh you know whatever but then so
then uh where'd you guys get food it was
um pub 47. shut up yeah
47. yeah
and he you know who owns dude if you
knew the people that run it were uh
like um
bartenders at twin peaks the managers
dude
i i don't know i i all i know was one
indication that i think he was an
alcoholic in hindsight oh absolutely in
hindsight but when i went there everyone
knew him i was like oh he's so cool like
whatever no he's there every day yeah
but then so then um i left and he calls
me on my way back and he's like oh come
take a shot at the gym with me like a
chat and at first i was like oh no i'm
not trying to drink tonight because it
was like my finals week that's why i was
home but he kept like going at it and i
was like you know what it'd be funny to
tell like my friends because i remember
thinking it'd be funny to tell my
friends i took a shot with my ex coach
because i was like 18 or 19. so i go to
the gym
and he like gives me a drink or whatever
and there's no one there but like stem
asked me to no alarm bells because i was
very sheltered you were yeah
and so be careful if you
plan to do this as a dude because we
tell friends yeah so then we go on
trying to think so we're sitting i'm
sitting with like there's two couches
there and i'm sitting like across from
him i'm already uncomfortable and yeah
guys this man is in his 60s 50s or 60s i
think at the time because i remember one
of the conversations we had was i was
like you're old
and if
two years younger than me like literally
and so i i went so i'm sitting there and
ah the weird okay this is gonna be pause
first yeah guys just so you know i've
always dated guys that were at least
four years older like that seems to be
the thing so i've been i've dated guys
that have been a decade older than me
like
a decade older
one but whatever so i have nothing
against that however i've been really
into
reading about like uh do you remember
that one guy courtney stodden and dave
hutchinson or whatever so when you're
telling me this that's what i have in my
mind keep going i don't know who they
are the girl that got married when she
was 16 and he was 50. i used to not
think that was weird as a kid i think he
was in his late 30s like i think he was
39 because i remember having a
conversation never mind different saying
that
actually i could look up his age right
now um
yeah i think we're talking about the
same person i think so too
because pub 47 the girls that bartended
there yeah
that's who we're talking about right
can you
no
look up uh super bowl when did the bears
win the super bowl in the 80s
i know that he was like he's on there
i'll know him when i see him
um
he would sit by himself and drink for
like hours dude
which is sad and you guys know my thing
about addiction i don't know what you'd
google super bowl
close bears if it's like businesses
okay
yeah it's 1985 okay
so then
1985.
i feel like he he was a big dude i feel
like he was what the block is that
somebody
like what are you what's his position
they're looking white
that's not true
oh that's cute like what the hell
um
why don't i just look up his like
wikipedia hold on oh you had
rob we don't don't say this yeah um
yeah
i feel like i like when i let's see
he
no i don't think we're talking i don't
think we're talking about the same
person i don't think so either this guy
was like
sorry yeah because i think cuz i
remember it was he was in his late 30s
because i said oh you're like my dad's
age you're old
he was trying to but i was 18. that's
not old nate you you think 39
that's kind of old like for an 18 year
old i mean i have i have like trauma
like i'm like old you know like but at
the same time i don't know his daughter
was like two years younger than me i
thought it was weird but
the are you surprised are you surprised
or do you think it's strange like let's
clarify
i was very surprised at the time because
what happened was we were sitting like i
was sitting across from him why you're
like a virgin what you were like a
virgin i was that's what i'm saying like
why would he you know yeah it's [ __ ]
up
no and so i
so he was across from me and he said i
said i wanted to go to a club downtown
okay and he was like oh if you go to
this club like you'll have to give the
bouncer up
and i was like what the [ __ ]
no you flash your tits maybe but like
well
you went i don't know why that was the
first where i was like okay well
i don't want to go to this i want to
know what he's doing right no guys if
you didn't catch that i don't know she
motioned uh
hey on job you know he's testing the
waters
testing it's kind of like when your ex
comes back into your life and like how
are you doing
he's like testing to see how you'd react
and so then he goes he says
like the gym don't want to go to the
club well yeah yeah i was like okay we
can find a different bar
we can find a different place to go
we can go anywhere else
but
but he so he goes what did he say he
said
you um then sonny goes you know like
hannah because my first time stand up
yeah jim the gym is empty right now we
could do anything you want i'm like what
do you mean marcus
and i'm like what what do you mean and
order pizza and then and then he's like
i think you know it i mean and like no
he didn't yeah and then i was like
holland and then so then i said
i do
um i was like i think i do know what you
mean
but i'm gonna like pretend like i don't
and then i laugh that was it and you
didn't try to persuade your dream now
then you know he that's this is how i
got him fired because after i left he
texted me he texted me so he said um he
said come back to the gym tonight and i
said for what and then he said like
um nothing just sex
and then and so then i was like
but i actually didn't i didn't get him
fired until years later because my mom
told me not to she i don't know why she
did this but my mom literally i wanted
to tell his wife what's your mom's name
um jen jen okay keep going um
because well no i think she had a
conversation with the
my club guys i see you in the chat she's
19.
okay
she's still in school or she came back
to visit him
guys
stop it
what are they saying it's it's because i
was over 18 right
yeah dude it's like okay on well no the
issue i had was he was waiting till
girls turned 18 to try to hook up with
him i found other stories too
so you're you're literally grooming yeah
you're ruining
like you forget what groominess i think
enough like i was training with him
since i was 14 and like as soon as this
happened i remembered all these
conversations that in hindsight were so
inappropriate yeah that he had with me
and so what i did was i wrote like a
letter and like i documented everything
i remembered everything that just
happened and then did you get paid
no oh no you don't understand why
wait wait wait do you know do you know
why i got him fired
because he he coached at my club and
that
happened behind the scenes wait so the
club is like like like a volleyball club
okay so he was a trainer at a volleyball
club but this is like where you're it's
like uh so okay i should i should
preface so i the volleyball club in our
murals no no this is competitive what's
that called very it's um
like traveling yeah travel it was travel
volleyball got it so he was the trainer
the head trainer he trained all the
girls on top of that he did one-on-one
training that was what i did with him in
the summers yeah gave me like the that's
where i got to know him you're giving me
nassar vibes yeah like if you know you
know so so then that's how i got to know
him like because it was the one-on-one
sessions over the summer that's why i
was very close with him i looked at him
as like a father figure yeah um and so
then on top of that a couple years later
i find out he is going to be a coach at
my high school my old high school on the
track team my sister's going to run
track oh stop yeah and so i i i was like
oh hell no i do not care who i have to
talk to
and so
wait so you lost me okay yeah hold on go
back okay
what else made you uncomfortable when
you had one-on-one coaching wait you're
saying like okay so in hindsight in
hindsight
okay got it it was little things but
like but you know i'd say as a 25 year
old when he he told me
before i went to college like that i was
going to get a bunch of attention from
boys because of my butt
but let me see it i didn't look
let me think
like and you know it's not wrong well
but that's not something you're saying
to a 17
because at the time and you know you
just kind of brushed it off you know
what i mean because you're okay you said
that at 17 yeah and there was other [ __ ]
too that like later i looked back
because this was so long ago now that
it's you know foggy yeah but like i
remember writing down like stuff he said
to me and i like went to the school
like while i was under age and so i'm
thinking because i remember saying like
you can tell me stuff you don't like you
don't tell your parents yeah who's well
you're the oh he said he said that
who who says that to
like he's grooming yeah and so that's
like like it doesn't get more i'm good
a couple years later i find out that he
is going to coach my sister because
otherwise i was just going to let it go
whatever but you thought it was like
just you like maybe you guys had like a
connection or whatever honestly yeah i
didn't i didn't think he was doing it to
multiple girls and that's that's where
we go wrong yeah like i totally get that
been in your situation yeah yeah so i
find out that he um is gonna coach my
sister and i don't
i don't even get along with that sister
like i have one sister that growing up
we never got along but i swear to god i
was not about to let her know so i still
had the text so i had his number i had i
printed everything out that i had from
him
and then
um and even inappropriate like stuff
he'd kind of sent me before there's
stuff that doesn't like when you say it
doesn't even sound inappropriate it's
only you that are going to experience it
and you remember it in hindsight you
don't have to like say it right because
like i always thought people were just
being nice i know and and it's it's hard
to explain because when you're 25 and
older like or 22 21 whatever your brain
sort of starts to like change a little
bit or you look back it does with
experience but at the time you don't and
so yeah i went to the principal and then
i got him fired and i don't know i'm
sure he's still doing like something
today with athletics but
yeah i like that's i'm so sorry i mean
i'm fine now i was sad at the time
because i like literally
like it's your fault too like forgetting
no i
like i
just don't have the balls to get them
like fired fired dude like i i and
that's my problem
but i also went in there to pick up like
my
meds when i had to go to downtown and i
was running late like i was in fishnets
like not saying that a victim's asking
for it i know what i mean but i was
being very friendly it was well and then
i after i find out that he he did this
to a girl that actually ended up
committing suicide he would like hook up
with her and like pay her rent all the
time and she ended up committing suicide
i don't know if it was it probably
wasn't just about him like you know what
guys i'm gonna say this
i know that guys are attracted to the 22
year old age and that's fine
but i'm telling you something goes on
between 18 without a host stage okay
let's make that clear something goes on
between the ages i'll say this
15
16 a lot and then 16 to 17 it's like
and then but 16 to 18
a lot but you're still even
one day after your freaking birthday
even up until 21 i would say 21 it's
like okay it can kind of settle but
you're still not aware of your own
behaviors like you are at 23. but when
men have the capacity to [ __ ] up women
sexually and i will say that mm-hmm so
stop it like seriously
no i know i've had mannose for people
like like com like i can tell they're
from the man of spirit comment because
i've told this story on like a tick tock
before
and it's weird they blame you like they
put the you the 17 18 year old
yeah
why'd you put yourself in that situation
or you liked the attention
yeah you do like the attention at that
age because you have to remember like
most people at school are bullying you
even if you're the nicest person you
know what i mean it's like well and i
liked that because my dad was gone a lot
he worked a lot so i liked the attention
from having like like an older male
figure to be honest
i thought i was cool i could buy the
liquor for kids and you know why i i'm
happy that the person i was involved
with was a good man like honestly
because i
could have been a lot
could have been a lot worse but you know
what i'm saying like they have the
capacity to do that i would have changed
anything about what i looked like i
would have gotten anything done and that
you look at kylie jenner and tyga
why the hell was that not on the news he
was grooming her at 13 dude and people
you know what it's not necessarily the
ages but i was trying to explain it's
like the the life experiences
and i'm telling you i used to think it
was [ __ ] when people say i'm like
i'm 16. i could date a 22 year old
there's not that much different blah
blah blah it's like uh no a lot of girls
i would say think that they're going for
the high value man because they're a
couple what
no i never age was never a thing for me
i never was attracted to like old guys
it wasn't that i was attractive remember
i don't get that like inkling it was
that and i've i told you this off camera
that they provided something for me that
and you guys know this so don't act all
surprised like the home guy [ __ ]
[ __ ] face
like he offered me a pl like his home so
and i thought i was gonna get killed at
mine so like for me that was the like
when you think about women finding men
back in the day because they want to
make sure that they don't die when they
give child birth it was the same idea
just like living it's it's interesting
because when i i never looked at guys as
like a means for money it wasn't like
that though it was like an escape it was
like it was like a home like he cared to
get me out of there because i genuinely
thought i was gonna like
but you know
we're not gonna talk about that but you
know what i'm saying like and he
you know i didn't have a car and he
would let me drive his truck and so like
i had a means to escape and so that's
what drew me to him
on
on the
he was emotionally unavailable you
[ __ ] my friend like there's just so
much i just couldn't i wasn't young i
was younger but i don't know guys i'm
just saying like you can go for young
girls i hope you do just be careful
be conscientious of what you're doing
you guys have a tendency to be
manipulative okay um there's ethical
game and i think it's going to become a
really big thing
but you don't and i know that it's so
easy to tell a girl
exactly what she wants to hear and what
i mean by that is if she says she wants
a relationship and you know damn well
that you wouldn't marry this [ __ ]
stop it
you [ __ ] him up when you act like you
will
be there or you want that do you see i
see a lot of girls
like the guy tells them that they just
don't listen actually more than i watch
their actions yeah
because they move a certain way trust me
if it doesn't line up you know um
you don't know i used to question it all
the time like is this one of those and
i've been fortunate to date really great
men so and there was like two that i
you know maybe talk smack about but they
were still and i know everybody laughs
when girls say he's like a guy though
this guy was
there's more to the story guys i just
can't say it on the internet okay but
what was i going where was i going with
that i don't know [ __ ] it was uh
uh he was a good dude but
he was a good tony do you remember that
was important i lost it
oh they tell so if i used to question
like okay how do i know if they're being
authentic or not i've been fortunate
that i've dated a lot of good men but
those two men showed me very well what
they do when they don't want to be with
you long term people are like why didn't
you settle with a high value guy guys
you didn't want to marry me
you out of your mind like
no
no and you want to know how i knew that
i'm thinking how did i know that i knew
it
because he made me
you know what i'm not going to say it on
the internet i'll tell you off camera
but it was
what
feminism would think is controlling
behavior
just use your imagination they would
think it's controlling behavior
and then [ __ ] you over so hard so what's
controlling behavior clothes like uh no
it's not that
but if let's say you try to get somebody
hypothetically i'm gonna say
hypothetically
you tell them to quit all their jobs
and then
all that stuff comes out as revenge to
try to hurt my feelings and stuff
[ __ ] you
dude like [ __ ] you that's somebody that
said all the right things in the
beginning you know he took me he tried
like he opened my eyes to so many
awesome places he told me everything i
wanted to hear
and
then [ __ ] played me dude but genuine
guys they'll be consistent they'll call
you every day they'll
they'll set the times
they'll if it doesn't work
it like we can have an honest
conversation like i don't think it's
working out and respect each other and
leave like it's nothing spiteful
it's never let me call you back i've
never had a guy and that's probably to a
fault but
guys have respected me so well that i
know it's like
you don't have to respect that woman
they've respected me so well that when i
said do do not contact me after
they never did like very good men
so i don't know that's me